عزيز الطائرات الاوكرانيه يحوم فوق
الكرملين والمبيد الروسي لها
تتوعد روسيا وتحدد اهداف الهجوم المضاد
وبعد انضمامها للميتو فنلندا تجري اول
اجراء عسكري يضايق الدب الروسي وموسكو ترد
على الفور وجنوب افريقيا تحسن بوتين وحلف
النيتو يعلن اقتراب ضم السويد فماذا عن
الرفض التركي كيف تعلن ان زمن الوساطات قد
ولى والصين ترفض اللقاء بالامريكان
واجتماع استخباراتي على اعلى مستوى حول
الجزائر ويضم اسرائيل ودوله عربيه وعناق
مصري تركي حار وفي السودان الخروقات تعكر
صفو الهدنه
مجزره المسيرات
[موسيقى]
لكن مهلا مهلا لقد حان وقت الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين ليتكلم والذي اتهمك في
تصريح صحفي بمحاوله ترهيب موسكو من خلال
توجيه ضربات للمراكز السكنيه وكشف بوتين
في تصريحاته عن تدمير روسيا للمقر الرئيسي
للاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه واضاف ان
النيتو خدع روسيا بتعهداته بعدم التمدد
نحو الشرق ليحاول ضم اوكرانيا وفق تعبيره
فهل يخفي بوتين امرا ما خلف تصريحات هذه
معارك المسيرات لا تنتهي هذه الايام لياتي
الدور هنا على مسيرات موسكو حيث اعلنت
سلاح الجو الاوكراني تدمير اكثر من 20
طائره مسيره خلال هجوم روسي ووصف رئيس
الاداره العسكريه في كييف الهجوم بانه
هائل وقال ان روسيا شنته باستخدام طائرات
ايرانيه الصنع فقط بحسب روترز واذا كانت
كل هذه الفوضى والدمار فقط بسبب المسيرات
الايرانيه فكيف سيكون الحال مع عوده
الطائرات الروسيه للعمليه ليعلنها رئيس
الوزراء الاوكراني الاسبق نيكولاي ازرو
صراحه لان الرئيس فولودي مرزلينيسكي وعد
بجعل اوكرانيا فرنسا او سويسرا جديده الا
انه ذهب الى ابعد الحدود وجعل منها
افغانستان جديده وذلك وفق تعبيره ومن
احلام اليقظه الاوكرانيه الى التهديد
والوعيد ليصرح وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
والاكسي انهم يملكون فرصا جديه بتحقيق
اختراق خلال صيف بفضل هجوم مضاد وشيك لجيش
بلاده على القوات الروسيه مؤكدا ان هذا
الهجوم المضاد بهدف الى العوده الى حدود
عام 91 المعترف بها دوليا لاوكرانيا بما
يشمل شبه جزيره القرم ليجيب الروس انكم لا
زلتم في احلام اليقظه يا هؤلاء وهنا تستمر
الاحلام الاوكرانيه حيث صرح ايجور فان
ايبو مدير مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني بان
اوكرانيا ستكون مستعده للتفاوض مع روسيا
فقط بشروطها الخاصه وقال ان الزمن البسطاء
ومقترحاتهم للازمه الاوكرانيه قد انتهى
فمن اين استمد كل هذه الشجاعه هل هناك
ايعاز غربي ليجيب وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
بان اوكرانيا تسلمت نحو 60 دبابه من الغرب
واعلنا عن احتياجها لحوالي 120 طائره
مقاتله ويجب ان يكون معظمها من طراز اف 16
وفق تعبيره برايكم هل يفعلها الغرب ويمد
اوكرانيا بهذه المقاتلات التي تعتبرها
موسكو ضمن خطوطها الحمراء لتاتي الاجابه
من القوانين الفيزيائيه يا ساده فلكل فعل
رده فعل وهنا اعلن الكسندر فولفوفيتش
سكرتيرو مجلس الامن في بيلاروسيا ان الدول
الغربيه لم تترك لبلاده اي خيار سوى نشر
اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه الروسيه مشيرا الى
انه من الافضل لهذه الدول عدم تجاوز
الخطوط الحمراء فيما يتعلق ببعض القضايا
الاستراتيجيه الرئيسيه نعم الغرب لن يترك
خيارا اخر وهنا اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه
لجنوب افريقيا على انها تضمن الحصانه
الدبلوماسيه للمشاركين في اجتماعات وزراء
الخارجيه في يونيو وقمه البريكس في اغسطس
وبذلك فان جنوب افريقيا تعطي حصانه مطلقه
لبوتين ليحضر اليها وذلك بعد ان اصدرت
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه امرا بتوقيفه
فهل يحضر بوتين تلك القمه ومن افريقيا الى
احدث عضو في النيتو نعم انها فنلندا والتي
اعلنت عن بدء اكبر المناورات العسكريه حيث
اعلن سلاح الجو الفنلندي عن استضافه عمليه
تحدي القطب الشمالي والتي تستمر اسبوعين
وتضم اربع عشره دوله 12 دوله عضو بالاضافه
الى السويد وسويسرا وتشمل المناوره 150
طائره في محاوله لاستفزاز روسيا بعد
الانضمام للحلم لياتي الرد الروسي فورا
وذلك باعلان الخارجيه الروسيه لاستدعاء
السفير فندي لدى موسكو
وابلغه بقرار تقليص الوجود القنصلي
المشترك بين البلدين بينما اكد الامين
العام لحلف الناتو في اجتماع لوزراء
خارجيه الحلف ان اتخاذ قرار بشان انضمام
السويد الى النيتو ممكن جدا قبل انعقاد
قمه
الاحداث والتطورات
نقلت صحيفه عن وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
قولها في بيان جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه
ابلغت الولايات المتحده لرفض دعوه ما في
اوائل مايو للقاء بين وزير الدفاع
ووزير الدفاع الوطني لجمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه ليشانكو في سنغافوره الاسبوع
المقبل مضيفه انها تؤمن ان التواصل
المفتوح هو السبيل لضمان عدم تحول
المنافسه الى الصراع نقلت صحيفه الخبر
الجزائريه عن مصادر وصفتها بالموثوقه
الاجتماعا مخابراتيا عقد على اعلى مستوى
في اسرائيل وذلك لزعزعه الاستقرار في
الجزائر بحسب الصحيفه والتي ذكرت ان
الاجتماع ضم اجهزه مخابرات الكيان
الصهيوني والاستخبارات الفرنسيه والمغربيه
بانتظار تعليق السلطات المغربيه التي تشهد
علاقاتها الجزائر توترا متزايدا في الفتره
الاخيره اتفق الرئيسان المصري عبد الفتاح
السيسي والتركي رجب طيب اردوغان على البدء
الفوري برفع العلاقات الدبلوماسيه وتبادل
السفراء بين البلدين واتفق على تدعيم
اواصر العلاقات والتعاون بين الجانبين دون
انفجار قوي جنوب العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم مترافقا مع تحليق لطائرات حربيه
مع سماع باصوات اسلحه مضاده للطيران وذلك
في ساعات الصباح الاولى بعد نهايه الهدنه
المعلنه في جده ومع بدايه لهدنه اخرى